[Aplausos]
[Música]
esta es la pregunta que todos nos
estamos haciendo estos días qué pasaría
si corea del norte y corea del sur se
reunificarán y se convirtieran en un
único país por supuesto no es algo que
tenga que ocurrir necesariamente al
menos a corto plazo pero está claro que
es una posibilidad que podría darse
mucho antes de lo que pensamos
hace solamente un año nadie habría dicho
que en la primavera de 2018
kim jong-un fuera a terminar dándose la
mano con el presidente surcoreano moon
jae-in así que qué pasaría si las dos
coreas se reunificarán lo cierto es que
ya hay un precedente histórico sí amigos
de visual político estoy hablando de la
reunificación alemana todos lo sabéis
alemania estaba dividida en dos bloques
alemania oriental por un lado con un
régimen socialista y alemania occidental
por el otro con un sistema capitalista
con la caída del muro de berlín la parte
oeste absorbió la parte del este desde
entonces el gobierno se ha gastado
auténticas fortunas para que los
alemanes orientales puedan tener una
calidad de vida similar a la de los
alemanes occidentales casi todos los
expertos aseguran que esto es un caso de
éxito muchos dicen que debería ser el
modelo a seguir para una posible
integración de las dos coreas pensando
bien en ambos casos tenemos una parte
capitalista y una socialista en ambos
casos una parte es mucho más rica que la
otra y en ambos casos hay un idioma hay
una cultura común
pero la pregunta es de verdad fue tan
fantástica la reunificación alemana o
solamente teoría podemos decir que los
alemanes orientales están al mismo nivel
que sus vecinos occidentales
pues la respuesta es que no incluso en
el fútbol se pueden ver todavía las
diferencias para que os hagáis una idea
a día de hoy todavía no hay ningún
equipo de alemania del este jugando en
la bundesliga los equipos occidentales
dominan el fútbol que resulta que es el
deporte nacional alemán y lo mismo pasa
en la economía aunque de eso vamos a
hablar más tarde pero donde las
diferencias dan más miedo es en la
política
[Música]
por ejemplo en las últimas elecciones el
partido de extrema derecha alternativa
por alemania entró en el parlamento como
la tercera fuerza política ya que no
adivináis donde consiguieron casi todos
los votos exacto en la antigua alemania
del street para que os hagáis una idea
esta es la primera vez desde 1961 en la
que un partido de extrema derecha tiene
una presencia tan grande en el
parlamento alemán y eso mis queridos
amigos de visual política es para
echarse a temblar
[Música]
y la venganza del este la furia en la
antigua república democrática alemana
ayudó a alternatiba por alemania así que
la pregunta que nos deberíamos hacer es
ha terminado ya el proceso de
reunificación alemana que podemos
aprender de este caso que se pueda
implementar en el de corea del norte y
corea del sur hoy vamos a responder a
estas preguntas pero antes antes voy a
hacer un pequeño paréntesis porque si
mis queridos amigos de visual político
nos habéis mandado más de 100 mil
mensajes pidiéndonos que hablemos
cataluña y tras muchos meses de trabajo
este jueves 11 de mayo hablaremos de
este tema vamos a contar con el mayor
experto de autodeterminación del mundo
así que estad atentos a nuestras
actualizaciones porque tantos meses de
espera van a merecer la pena y ahora sí
vamos a ver un poco de historia
el ganador se queda con todo tras la
segunda guerra mundial los aliados
dividieron alemania en cuatro zonas de
ocupación militar
los británicos se quedaron con el
noroeste francia con el suroeste eeuu
con el sur y la unión soviética con el
este
podríamos hablar durante horas sobre
todos los detalles de esta ocupación
pero entonces estaríais horas mirándome
mover las manos y os daría un ataque
epiléptico así que en resumen a partir
de 1949 alemania quedó dividida en dos
países
el oeste capitalista con capital en bonn
que se llamó la red pública federal
alemana y el este socialista con capital
en berlín este que se llamó la república
democrática alemana poco a poco berlín
oeste se convirtió en una gran metrópoli
capitalista como podría ser cualquier
ciudad estadounidense
mientras tanto berlín éste se convirtió
en una copia miniatura de moscú la
constitución de alemania oriental decía
que sus ciudadanos tenían toda clase de
derechos incluido el derecho a huelga
pero la realidad era muy distinta todas
las decisiones se tomaban desde el
llamado poli puro que era algo así como
el comité directivo del partido
socialista y prácticamente el único
medio de comunicación era un periódico
financiado por el partido socialista que
además era prácticamente el partido
único y aquí podéis ver un ejemplo de su
objetividad y calidad informativa
[Música]
nueva alemania el órgano central del
partido socialista unido hoy celebramos
100 años de la publicación del
manifiesto comunista como os podéis
imaginar la economía de la alemania
oriental estaba totalmente centralizada
y prácticamente todas las fábricas y
empresas eran propiedad del estado para
que os hagáis una idea el gobierno
fijará los precios de todos los bienes y
servicios es decir que cada año el
gobierno publicaba una lista con todos
los precios que tenían que tener las
cosas ejemplo una barra de pan cinco
marcos un walkman de importación
japonesa mil marcos y así con todo en
muchos casos aunque tuvierais el dinero
para comprar las cosas tenéis que
poneros en lista de espera ahí está el
ejemplo de los coches los famosos
trabant a alemanes si queréis comprar
uno del día hay que esperar hasta diez
años desde que lo pedí ice hasta que se
entregaban las llaves
os podéis imaginar este tipo de
políticas generaban escasez desempleo y
en fin que miles de alemanes orientales
quisieran escapar a la parte occidental
y que creéis que hizo el gobierno del
este para evitarlo pues construir un
muro el famoso muro de berlín por
supuesto que para justificar esta
decisión el partido socialista decía que
querían evitar infiltraciones fascistas
en su país pero la realidad era
exactamente lo contrario
vamos podéis imaginar las relaciones
entre las dos alemanias no eran
precisamente amistosas alemania
occidental no reconocía a la parte este
y entendían que ellos eran los
auténticos representantes de toda
alemania y lo mismo pasaba al revés
[Música]
recuerda algo si es más o menos la misma
relación que tenían corea del norte y
corea del sur pero sin bombas atómicas y
al igual que ha ocurrido hace poco con
las dos coreas en este caso las dos
alemanias normalizaron sus relaciones en
los años setenta sin embargo el
auténtico punto de inflexión llegó en el
año 1989
[Aplausos]
la república democrática alemana
celebraba su 40 aniversario nadie se
imaginaría que también sería el último
pero eso es lo que tiene la historia que
es impredecible y los cambios se dieron
a velocidad de crucero tan sólo diez
meses después de la caída del muro de
berlín las dos alemanias se unieron en
lo que hoy conocemos como alemania
la nueva alemán ya está aquí tras 45
años finalmente tenemos la aritmética
correcta y tenemos una alemania en una
europa unida y libre james baker
secretario de estado pero seamos
honestos en realidad esto no fue una
unión de dos países distintos sino una
absorción básicamente el 3 de octubre de
1989 alemania del este desapareció como
país independiente y pasó a formar parte
de lo que era alemania del oeste desde
luego era una buena idea pero también
tenía sus puntos flacos
[Música]
al fin juntos por fin las dos alemanias
se habían reunificado pero no todo era
tan bonito veréis alemania occidental ya
era un país rico con empresas
productivas y de tecnología puntera
alemania oriental era todo lo contrario
fábricas obsoletas baja productividad y
sobre todo rentas mucho más bajas
no esto por no hablar de que los dos
países tenían sistemas políticos
antagónicos es decir una situación muy
parecida a la de las dos coreas aunque
en el caso alemán las diferencias eran
menos extremas
como os podéis imaginar si quieres que
un país pueda funcionar
tienes que armonizar este tipo de
diferencias y os preguntaréis qué
hicieron los alemanes pues básicamente
alemania occidental exportó todas sus
leyes regulaciones y sistema fiscal a la
alemania oriental
a cambio el oeste se encargó de pagar
todos los gastos del este
eso significa que de la noche a la
mañana los impuestos de los ciudadanos
occidentales servían para pagar todas
las carreteras ferrocarriles y calles
que usaban los alemanes orientales en
principio suena bastante lógico nos
parece es decir si un país rico se junta
con otro muy pobre tiene sentido que el
uno ayude al otro a recuperarse pero mis
queridos amigos de visual política la
economía es mucho más complicada y a
veces dar dinero no es suficiente
[Música]
por muchas ayudas económicas esta
reunificación supuso el colapso absoluto
de la economía de alemania del este y os
preguntaréis por qué pensando bien de
repente alemania era un único mercado y
era un mercado donde las empresas del
oeste eran mucho más competitivas que
las del este por ejemplo en la alemania
comunista tenían esa marca de
automóviles de la que ya hemos hablado
los famosos trabant que comparados con
un bmw o un audi
eran un auténtico juguete y eso explica
que la demanda de estos coches cayera en
picado tras la reunificación
[Música]
los alemanes del este abandonan sus
trabajos en praga así que imaginad la
situación trabajáis en la fábrica de
trabajo y de repente la empresa cierra
porque nadie compra sus coches después
vais al supermercado y resulta que todos
los productos que compráis están hechos
en el oeste que para algo tienen las
mejores fábricas y que todo es mucho más
caro porque sorpresa
de repente vives en un país rico donde
todos los precios son mucho más altos
pero eso no es todo
imagina por ejemplo que sois un jubilado
de alemania del este
vuestra pensión estaba calculada en base
a los precios de la época comunista pero
de repente estábamos en 1990 y cuando
vais al supermercado el pan cuesta lo
mismo que la alemania del oeste en otras
palabras es tres veces más caro lo
entendéis lo que quiero decir la gente
joven al menos podía emigrar o buscar un
trabajo mejor pero aquí puede hacer un
abuelo que se acaba de jubilar
[Música]
sin embargo la auténtica guinda del
pastel era el cambio de divisas las dos
alemanias tenían dos divisas distintas
con distintos valores así que los
ministros de finanzas de ambos países se
juntaron en una sala y decidieron fijar
una tasa de cambio de uno a uno por
supuesto esto funcionaba muy bien en la
teoría pero en nadie en el mercado real
te daba un marco occidental a cambio de
un marco oriental
por ejemplo la mayor parte de los bancos
deberían dos marcos orientales a cambio
de un marco occidental y en el mercado
negro la tasa de cambio podía llegar
hasta los 12 y marcos orientales por un
marco occidental
[Música]
en otras palabras que el dinero que
tenían ahorrados los alemanes orientales
de la noche a la mañana valía muchísimo
menos y con esta situación que creéis
que hizo el gobierno alemán la respuesta
a estas subvenciones subvenciones y más
subvenciones de repente los
contribuyentes del oeste no sólo pagaban
infraestructuras sino también la salud
la educación y muchos otros gastos de
sus vecinos del strip para que os hagáis
una idea hablamos de más de 70 mil
millones de dólares todos los años desde
1990 esto es algo así como organizar 4
juegos olímpicos todos los años y la
pregunta es después de 30 años podemos
decir que ha terminado el proceso de
reunificación podríamos decir que
alemania es por fin un país igualitario
pues la respuesta es sí
y a la vez no ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
juntos pero no revueltos según un
estudio muchos alemanes dicen que nunca
se casarían con alguien de la otra
alemania y tres cuartas partes de la
población piensa que todavía hay
diferentes mentalidades entre el este y
el oeste el 10% de los alemanes
orientales nunca ha puesto un pie en la
otra parte del país y en lo que respecta
a la economía también hay grandes
diferencias
si os fijáis en la gráfica veréis que
durante los primeros años de la
reunificación la renta per cápita del
este era de unos nueve mil cuatrocientos
euros mientras que en el oeste era de 22
mil euros hoy en día las diferencias son
de 27.000 frente a 41 mil euros si son
unas diferencias un poquito más suaves
pero habría que ser muy tonto para decir
que no hay ninguna diferencia y por
supuesto también tenemos el choque
cultural según una investigación de la
universidad de jacko en bremen los
alemanes del este son los menos
tolerantes con las minorías y con los
derechos lgtb y no sólo hablamos de
estudios fijaos en las últimas
elecciones
[Música]
los votantes del oeste votan
generalmente a partidos moderados como
los demócratas cristianos que es el
partido de angela merkel o los
socialdemócratas en el este sin embargo
es donde consiguen votos de los partidos
más radicales desde alternativa por
alemania que es de extrema derecha hasta
delinque que es de extrema izquierda y
esto podría ser un problema porque puede
que llega el momento en el que los
alemanes del este con sus votos terminen
secuestrando el debate político alemán y
cambiando las políticas que afectan el
país entero
volviendo al ejemplo de las dos coreas
imaginad qué ocurriría si los
norcoreanos votarán a partidos
comunistas y que de repente un líder
como kim jong-un terminará tomando
decisiones que afectarán también a los
surcoreanos desde luego esto podría ser
un problema en definitiva que hay muchas
cosas buenas que tendríamos que resaltar
sobre la reunificación alemana a fin de
cuentas si seguís visual político desde
hace tiempo no nos va a sorprender si os
digo que alemania es un país modélico
hay muchísimas cosas pero como siempre
decimos no todo es tan bonito y si
hubiera una reunificación de las dos
coreas hay muchos riesgos que tendríamos
que tener en cuenta
pero ahora turno para vosotros creéis
que los alemanes del este con una
mentalidad más radical que los del oeste
podrían terminar cambiando radicalmente
el debate político en alemania creéis
que la reunificación alemana pese a
todos sus problemas podría ser un modelo
para la península coreana podéis
dejarnos vuestras respuestas en los
comentarios y como siempre no olvidéis
que sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas y que jueves de esta semana
hablaremos por fin de cataluña así que
suscribiros a visual políti para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y compartirlo con
vuestros amigos un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]